Film Courage: What did FOR THE LOVE OF GEORGE
teach you about screenwriting?
Nadia Jordan: I mean it really taught me the
whole to be honest because this was my first
feature.
It really taught me…you know it’s very
different when you write a book or a story.
I’m really aware of how pacing is so important
and dialogue is so important and how my co-writer
has a tendency to make things really wordy
and I’m somebody who does not particularly
like wordy films.
Woody Allen is great.
All his films are extremely wordy and so yeah
visual is very important, location is very
important, you have to think when you’re
writing, it needs to translate into film,
right?
So it just basically taught me the whole process.
How to make a movie, it all begins with a
good script and it’s so important when you
start writing.
It can’t just read well, it has to translate
on the screen.
Film Courage: What did it teach you in the
sense of completing something or the idea
of something and then the actual time and
energy it takes to do it?
You know, sort of taking away the mystique
of “Oh, I’m making a movie!”
And how exciting it sounds, but also how stressful
I’m sure it can be.
Nadia Jordan: Even now people say “Well,
that’s great.
You made a movie.”
And when you’re in the middle of it, it’s
like…I mean obviously none of us would be
in this industry doing this if we didn’t
enjoy it and it wasn’t something we wanted
to do.
But for me there were so many struggles and
so many problems on the producing side of
it and so many curveballs like the [George
Clooney] engagement.
And even just like financing and trying to
get a director and having producers sign on
and then drop out.
It was just so much.
And it really kind of taught me…I mean there
were days when just basically I wanted to
give up and thought this just isn’t worth
it.
But you just get up and say “Just keep going.”
And it really just kind of made me realize
that if you’re passionate about something,
there isn’t anything to it and it’s something
you can be really proud of.
And to now look back and think I did this
feature and it started as just this little
idea and I’m proud that it’s my first
feature that I’ve written (the first screenplay),
the first film I’ve produced, the film that
I played (a feature) that I played a lead
in like this.
But for me I’m just kind of realizing it
now, now it’s out and people are watching
it.
Because until then you are just so caught
up in all of the having to get it finished,
having to get it made.
And someone was saying to me at like every
level 50 million, 100 million, there are always
problems, you know from the producing side.
There are always things that come up and you
just have to learn to deal with them.
For me now, I’ve learned so much on this
film, like hopefully the next one is going
to be a little bit easier because I think
I’ve faced every problem you can face in
making a film.
And you can get through it and I think as
long as you have the passion and determination
and you don’t give up, it’s worth it.
It is worth it.
I now have a film.
Film Courage: Which has distribution.
Nadia Jordan: Yes, which has distribution
and people are watching.
And you see the reviews come out and it’s
like “Something I made that people are actually
enjoying it.”
Because you get so caught up in trying to
make it good and the sound and the edit, the
distribution and everything that goes with
it, you kind of forget what drove you to make
it in the first place and the whole vision.
And seeing in the end that people are actually
enjoying it, it’s a really good feeling.
Film Courage: Have you always been a finisher?
You know how some people start many things
and then they leave them half, sort of undone
(for various reasons).
Do you always make sure you finish everything?
Nadia Jordan: I mean…I’m not someone who
starts loads of different things.
I have to be really passionate about something
to actually get so involved in it.
But if I am, then I will always finish it.
I always want to get going with things.
If I have to sit and read a contract…like
for example I hate board games where I have
to sit and read the rules.
Let’s just make them up as we go along.
I don’t want to sit there and read the whole
rule book.
Let’s just make them up.
And that’s the kind of thing I just blag
it.
But if it’s something I’m really passionate
about, I’ll always see through it.
I hate not having an ending and having something
half-done.
I want to do it whole-heartedly, if it’s
something I actually want to do.